red sox starting pitcher 8th and baldy 4
and 2
and an era 420. rojas at second
looking for the sweep and that's going
to be in there for strike three
sits down rojas the last time out for
eval he had four strikeouts his high on
the season is 10.
he gets the first battle with a 97 mile
an hour fastball right at the bottom of
the strike zone
that'll send up mike trout swinging a
miss down he goes strike three
back-to-back case to start it for nate
wow two hitters two strikeouts for a
vivaldi
early in the ball game
and is 0-1 and contact here's chavis
from shallow right
nathan avaly getting off quickly one two
three go to the halos
jose quintana yeah my go-to is for him
to have success today against this red
sock lineup but it's been a good lineup
is trust fastballs for big outs 17
strikeouts with his fastball especially
above the strike zone a consistent 11-5
break on his curveball
that'll do it and that's exactly what he
did gooby he went fastball low change-up
away and as predicted by you
got a swing and a miss it's amazing how
many punch-outs he can get with his
fastball especially when it's above the
strike zone
10 home runs for this man rafael devers
fastball strike three that one runs away
back-to-back strikeouts to open things
up
that's now 36 strikeouts at 21 and
two-thirds
broke his bat into center field mike
trout is there and a one-two-three
inning for quintana
walsh down the line we go it rockets
into the corner
played very gently by gonzales rendon
into third walsh with the double jared
double number seven on the year
a little more opportunity and a little
bit more playing time for taylor ward
to the right side base hit
one run score they'll stop the runner at
third and walsh taylor ward with an rbi
he gets it done got a pitch out over the
plate just punched it the right
the piece of hitting fifth rbi for
taylor ward
runners on first and third now
pops that one to the right side heads
down
into the corner that one goes hustling
on around contact
is rewarded as we've seen it a couple of
times with ward
and now with gosselin it's two to
nothing halos is the goose loose
on that one oh the goose is loose
to drew butera in on the hands
fights it off into left field it's down
onto the plate the second run sliding in
safe the angels add on
this is the start they're looking for as
they jump
up top four to nothing this time dealing
with xander bogart's
253 career starts
and all these pitches gooby are in play
if you jump ahead everything suddenly is
in play as bogarts goes down and
challenge a
fastball hitter with a fastball upstairs
i'm just liking his pace there's
something about him this afternoon
jose quitana he's he's in that fight
mode
boy staying stubborn in
just committed to working it in not
letting the red sox get their hands
extended
two very strong innings to start things
for quintana
this guy tied for seventh in the
american league and runs bad at him with
29.
it's that one nice play on the slide by
dolbeck flips it ahead
of aldi there and plenty of time bobby
d's made a couple of really nice plays
in this one
that was really nice beautiful gonzalez
on it first
that's into left field here comes
gosselin that'll drop down for a base
hit back-to-back singles
so the red sox got it going on at last
our ooze will be next
all right bottom of the lineup taking
over back-to-back hits that was similar
right there i believe that was a
fastball up in the zone able to get on
top of it for the line drive
our use starting at short and there's a
drive down the left-field line
that's going to keep on rolling to the
wall gonzalez in
plawecke they're going to wave him in no
he's going back
bayless had him coming and then sent him
back to third
and the red sox are on the board it's
4-1
both runs could have scored on this but
i think the
the trail runner held up on his own
the 2-2 got him outside corner that
strike three
and he painted that one on the outside
corner
fastball elevated popped up looking
into foul territory now back in the fair
territory and puts it away what a nice
bounce back
for the left-hander quintana arundo
score 4-1
and then this road trip on the right
note
pulls his hands in gives it a ride in
the left center field
mike trout is there he puts it away
we'll be warming up guys in the bullpen
i'll let you know mike trout all for one
with a walk
that led the lead he's going to get out
on strikes here his last full season was
two years ago
he stole all of 11. he is in a bad way
at the plate right now does not have a
hit in the series
got it by him a big swing and a miss he
puts away random
second strikeout in the inning for
ovaldi this man jared walsh has doubled
off him he's also grounded out
runner goes and it's hit the other way a
drive martina is back he's gonna have to
play this off the green
ohtani they're gonna send in here comes
the throw throw the home plate is
waiting for him
martinez jd on the button
to cut him down wow kevin plawecki one
for one
he'll take a high fly this one deep to
left field
and kiss that one goodbye man did he
jump over it
up and over that wall for his first home
run of the season yes sir
an absolute no doubter rafael devers has
struck out two times
there's a swing and a high fly ball
right field
watch this baby carry it is gone
well raphael deborah is blistering
another home run his second in his many
games
full extension just take oh he took
advantage of that
shot into right field driving back
gonzalez reaches up and makes the play
right feels his best spot
you can put that guy anywhere 2-2 home
swing and a foul tip to the mint held by
vasquez
barnes just keeps on mowing them down
mike trout now oh for three
trout fastball in popped up right side
here come the red sox together there's a
base hit for trout
you hate to see that bottom line there's
your tying run
and it gives shohei ohtani a chance to
swing the bat
shohei high fly ball to the corner it
goes into deep right field ohtani
oh my he did it chauhay
gives the halos the lead he gets it done
wow one and two one
strike away mike with the one two got
him
the angels get it they take it right
back they come home with the victory
and the halo shines bright tonight what
a comeback victory
shohei ohtani showtime